In today's challenge episode
we're going to try and split
a ping pong ball in half,
play with a net
filled with holes,
and more.
Let's get into it!
From the edge,
hit the gong!
No...
Yes!
The going has struck.
That's a sign for you to hit subscribe!
We're going to try to split
a ping pong ball by hitting it there.
We did this challenge five years ago
onto a knife and we got it to stay there.
If it doesn't work,
then this is a great
promotion for our balls.
I'm just going to be under here.
It hit?
It had no effect at all.
Oh, dear.
It just bounced straight off.
I'm not overly confident
that we'll actually get this.
It chipped!
Take some chocolate
and then we'll get this.
Chocolate racket?
Did someone say chocolate racket?
This is a mini chocolate racket.
Once we hit 5 million subscribers,
we're going to make the world's biggest
chocolate racket.
So make sure you hit subscribe!
We had been smashing ping pong balls
at this axe for the last 45 minutes
and we were starting to lose hope.
So we switched to a knife,
but still we were only getting
chipped balls
and not the perfect
slice in half that we were looking for.
Got to believe in yourself Emil.
We weren't going to give up.
We froze the balls for the night,
took the blades to be sharpened,
and got a blowtorch
just in case it still wouldn't split.
Stick until the end of the video
to see the results.
Good.
I got it!
I got it back!
Oooh nooo!
That was a roller!
Touched from here.
Exactly what I tried.
Go Emil!
Come on Emil!
I almost made it though.
First one to fill their side with ping pong balls,
wins!
And the loser
gets to enjoy one raw egg.
So disgusting.
Good luck!
I'm so so nervous.
I'm so nervous!
Disgusting eating a raw egg!
No that's going your side!
Yes!
Come on!
1-0 to Otto!
Give one for me.
Nooo concentrate...
No!
Yes!
Thank you Otto!
Otto equalized it for Miikka.
Very nice of you!
You weren't getting anything on!
This would be better for me
if I didn't serve at all.
I'm going to change tactic.
Thank you.
Noooo!
Good tactic Miikka thank you!
Thought I'd put a bit of spin and then...
Try the spin!
I don't think so.
No that's going to your side!
It literally bounced from...
It came out!
Wrong edge.
Oh it bounced...
I've figured out if you go around the side,
like that.
Thanks!
Good match!
Bottoms up!!
It's, it's not that bad.
No?
No.
The ping pong ball slice is still coming up,
so watch until the end.
I'm going for a triangle.
Surprise!
I didn't see at all.
Like, I was like, it's coming here
and then it's suddenly there.
Ooooh!
Good shot!
Oh you got it through!
You know this is so much harder than it looks.
I think we should make even more holes.
Samuli what do you think about the net?
Little strange...
And obviously I...
Yes!
Sorry!
This is so confusing!
Jokke!
Just in time!
Now we have holes!
Look at my shirt,
look at my rubber!
It touched!
Okay.
It actually went through!
Ooh slap...
I was like...
Slapshot!
You catch that?
Yes!
*Jokke laughter*
Like that!
That's impossible!
That's the good one!
Sorry!
That's Jokke's special shot!
Emil smash!
Shouldn't have gone for it.
6-10.
Match point to Jokke!
Good job!
Well done!
Champion of the hole table!
Thank you everybody!
Until next table!
It's a new day,
these balls...
they have been in the freezer for 24 hours.
But the more important thing,
we have got the axe and the knife
sharpened.
By a professional blacksmith.
No matter what it takes,
we are gonna make this happen!
Axe, plus frozen balls.
Lets start hitting!
Yeah we've seen this before.
Maybe if we reach the certain point,
then it will just crack open.
You know what time it is Otto?
The blowtorch!
I don't know if it's going to make any difference but...
This has happened before.
This flew at me!
So we got it?
We got it!
Splitting a ping pong ball,
not quite in half.
We are pleased, but we are not satisfied.
I think...
We got something!
It's a mini table tennis racket!
I think we can get the perfect slice.
Let's move on to the badminton racket.
Just to spice it up a bit.
Yeah it's going a lot harder.
We did it!?
Yees!
This is almost...
Okay yeah, that is it!
It's not perfect but,
it's good enough.
It's good enough!
But the main thing is,
Yes.
No.
Very good!
Wohoo!